à l'occasion des 50 ans de l'école
d'aviation de chasse de Tours une
exposition sera inaugurée ce week-end
dans le péristyle de la mairie un avion
Alpha Jet aux couleurs de l'anniversaire
sera exposée en face du Palais des
Congrès Vinci mais c'est bien sûr cet
après-midi sur la base aérienne de Tours
Nord qu'il y avait le plus de mouvements
d'abord avec les remises de décoration
puis la remise des brevets de pilotes
aux élèves formés sur la base mais ce
qui a fait lever les yeux au ciel ce
sont surtout les démonstrations en
musique il y a d'abord la patrouille
cartouche dorée ces trois upsilon qui
ont fait des exercices de voltige
enfin le passage furtif mais passage
quand même de la PAF la Patrouille de
France qui s'est ensuite dirigée vers le
centre-ville et a descendu l'avenue de
Gramont l'Alpha Jet sera exposé tout le
week-end face au Vinci quant à
l'exposition dans le péristyle retraçant
50 ans de formation d'aviation de chasse
à Tours elle se tiendra jusqu'au 24 juin